hi max
hiya how are you i am very well first of
all congratulations on being absolutely
fabulous in this film oh thank you so
much
uh you've talked about how this movie
was your first professional job in
anything film tv or theater so
was acting something you'd been thinking
about doing when did the desire to even
do this happen
yeah i mean i've i've
i mean for as long as i can remember
i've wanted to be an actor
um
and
i suppose i really sort of
felt serious about maybe taking it as a
career when i um finished college which
was
i think maybe finishing i was about 18
so maybe that's a high school age in
america i'm not really sure about
the difference between the education but
yeah i did like drama and theater
studies and
music and i was like picking my subjects
and i decided okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
go to drama school i wanted to go to
drama school and to study musical
theater because i loved singing and i
loved acting and i wanted to like do so
i didn't want to give up either
um and then i didn't get into any drama
schools that i wanted to go to that year
um when i auditioned
and
i
then took a place on a foundation course
where i was for a year and that's where
i truly sort of began um sort of my
craft and learning about the industry
and
that's where it all really started for
me
when you started auditioning for this
what were you thinking i mean were you
thinking that
okay i have a shot at this i could get
this were you thinking there's no way in
in hell that i'm gonna get this so i'm
just gonna go for it like how did that
what were you thinking about it when you
started auditioning i was i wasn't
getting this role in my head like i was
there was no way i i knew that they'd
seen thousands of people already i knew
that they were still seeing lots and
lots of people and i didn't have an
agent
um you know a movie for me um in my
second year of college at the time felt
so unattainable and so far from reality
um
so i had i literally was probably i was
auditioning thinking oh i'm just gonna
use this as experience i'm just gonna
um be open i'm going to um get to like
meet a really cool british and america
oh he's british but he's worked in
america a lot
amazing theater director and jonathan
butterworld
and just
use use it as an experience and it
it wasn't until really they offered me
the job that i was i realized what was
going on and i was like wow okay i'm
gonna have to do this now
what was that moment how did they tell
you how did you react did you think
somebody was pranking you like how how
did that go
well yeah yeah it definitely felt like
an episode of like the prank patrol or i
don't know what the american equivalent
is but i was in um i'd worked with
jonathan
the director shaheen bagel the casting
director and cat marshall our associate
producer all day we were meeting loads
of potential deans who who's the who's
jamie's
um
the guy who bullied jamie in in the film
um
and
it got to the end of the day and
jonathan was like oh you know max i just
don't think i don't think we've got what
we need out of the scene would you
remind doing some
improvisation and i was like
okay okay okay this is where i'm gonna
lose the job this is where like they're
gonna they're gonna realize that i'm not
good and i just you do all these things
in your head where you're like i'm not
worthy i'm not worthy i'm not worthy
anyway we launched into the scene the
sneaky associate producer cat is filming
me and i didn't realize and jonathan
launches into the scene we do the scene
and he just says how would you feel
if i offered you the role of jamie and
everybody's talking about jamie and i
just
i think jonathan said i didn't and it
apparently i jumped around the room and
i i was like ah
craziness and then i called my i
definitely remember calling my mom but i
remember so clearly pausing for what
felt like an eternity and
being just aghast and like not believing
it yeah
what sort of pressure and responsibility
did you feel taking on this character
it's the title character you're leading
this film what is that like and what is
the first day on set like oh gosh um
yeah i felt a lot of pressure
but um
our amazing production company in warp
films and film four put an amazing team
around me to make sure that i was you
know guided so carefully and
through the process of you know
prepping my my sides and making sure i
knew what to expect on when i came on
set but my first day which i don't think
anyone could prepare me for was with
richard e grant you know oscar-nominated
actor you you're turning up to set and
we filmed like one of the section 28
marches was our first day so it was like
a big crowd day
um and it was really daunting um
and i don't think anyone can truly
prepare you for that moment i don't
think any amount of training
any amount of people telling you what
the experience is going to be like can
prepare you for being
in the moment on set
the moment before the ad cause um
action or the direct calls action and
you have to just roll with it and
and it took a while to it took a while
for me to you know get into the flow of
what my working day would feel like but
what i would say is that i just try to
really enjoy it and just be in the
moment every second
and
every time every every time yeah i love
the relationship between jamie and hugo
and
i mean what was it like to explore that
to have richard e grant as a scene
partner to really get to
play with him because that that
character also just seems so playful
yeah i mean richard as well is also so
playful and fun so um he was amazing and
working with him was so great and we got
to do it so early on in the shoot as
well and that was
whilst i was going through my crash
course of filmmaking i was also
able to do that with like
a really super amazing actor that was
so generous and
i remember we shot it was like in the
first week of the scene towards the end
of the movie
with me and richard in the shop which is
like quite an emotionally charged scene
and um we hadn't filmed lots of the
stuff leading up to that and um i
remember richard giving just as much if
not more when he was behind the camera
and not being shot
and taught me so much about you being
generous and just being there to listen
one of my favorite moments in this even
though there are a lot of great moments
in this film but one of my favorite
moments is the song that jamie and his
mom sing together
what was it like to shoot that to really
get to look into each other's eyes and
sing that song it just it's such a
beautiful moment
it was really emotional actually i think
anyone can relate to a moment in their
life where they've pushed away someone
who loves them
out of um
out of you know
you know going when someone's going
through their own struggles pushing away
someone who's you know just trying to be
there for them um
and
again sarah is an amazing actor and
i just truly connected with her in that
moment and i mean the music is is so
gorgeous and dan gillespie sales and tom
who wrote wrote this music just
the music sores and it's like such an
intimate moment and to share that with
sarah was really lovely and
um
again another moment that i felt was
that i'll cherish and it will stay with
me forever it's just you know
allowing myself to pour my own heart
into these characters um and that was a
moment truly where i felt like i was
pouring lots of myself into the role
i i've been a dancer since i was four
but i am also one of the clumsiest
people ever so i can have great
appreciation for anyone who can wear
heels like this
i'm also very clumsy too yeah i'm the
worst it's that whole thing they always
say dancers are the clumsiest people and
nobody believes that but it is very
important because we're just so free
with our limbs they just go everywhere
yeah very bad what was it like to walk
in the heels to have to get used to i
mean you have to look confident in them
which i could never do
yeah i mean i
i hadn't really had any heels training i
hadn't done any hills dance classes or
anything before this process um but i
was so i was so game i was so up for it
i was so
open to it and um i had an amazing heels
coach sean niles who's danced like kylie
minogue and stuff like that so to have
him be like by my side you know
teaching me the ways teaching me how to
walk um and giving me loads of tips and
tricks was so important but my feet hurt
you know 12 weeks almost my feet i've
taken a break now i'm in trainers today
and no i'm going to be sticking in
trainers for a little while
what was it like to see the full drag
look to see how that would look like on
you to get to do the first drag
performance what was that whole
experience like it was really exciting
i'm a huge fan of drag race so i was so
so excited um to see myself looking as
amazing as so many of the queens that
i've looked up to over the last you know
a few years um but also incredibly
daunting you know when drag
um
when drag happen like when it happens it
takes takes over so
you know you're really like conscious of
like people reacting to you and how it's
making them feel and you know it spurs
you on a bit when you when you can see
you know someone's a little bit you know
scared or a little bit like
infatuated with your beauty you know it
it does something to you it makes you
feel powerful
yeah it feels very otherworldly and
magical
yeah the thing i like in drag queens too
is like um you know your favorite like
animated character when you go see them
at a theme park and they're they're
dressed up in these costumes
that's for me like that's what drag is
it's play it's
it's character and
that's why i'm such a huge fan of it
because you can actually meet these
people in real life and they're real and
they exist
i love that jamie wins people over by
just being himself by being fully okay
with that and making no apologies for
that yeah
how freeing do you think that really is
for him especially you know having that
moment at the dance
yeah i think a lot i think um
a lot of his
his stuff i'll call it
his internal world is built up to that
moment to that dance um
because
as well as you know the community around
him shifting and having their thoughts
and feelings about him i think he truly
goes through
um
a change in how he sees himself and
um
in this film and
and i think for him that moment of
you know one of his
you know
do do i think miss hedges you know
opposed to jamie no do i do i think that
she's just
trying to you know let let a kid know
that um
they they can't always be the center of
attention and they can't always do that
yes and jamie has to go on that process
of you know learning that he has to
he has to take his place and also make
room for others
um you know he's
and that's what that moment is you know
and i think that's that i think that
realization comes at the prom when he's
when he when when he arrives in whatever
he arrives in um
and i suppose that moment of
that moment of joy when all of his his
um
classmates are sticking up for him is he
probably feels well he definitely felt
very supported by
his his community around him which all
of them took a shift you know they all
saw him do the show and all of that
stuff so
you know it's really it's
not a lovely moment in the film yeah
have you thought about where you go from
here and what the next step for you is
how are you looking to approach this
whole acting thing now
oh yeah i'm approaching it head on
um i've been really lucky over the last
year and in the pandemic i've shot a few
more films um
which i can't talk about unfortunately
they're not announced but um you know
this film has been a true springboard
for me into the world of acting and
um
i just continue to grow and learn and do
things that challenge me and hopefully
the work that i do moving forward
challenges me as well as an audience
when it comes to roles and projects
do you
have things that you know you want to do
or is it more about knowing what you
don't want to do and being open to
everything else
um i think i'm just quite open i do know
that i want to do like some sort of
superhero movie i know that i want to do
a biopic that isn't musical
um
that maybe maybe is like a sports person
or a um
a fashion designer of some sort um
because i just
it would just be really cool because i
loved i love having anchors that are
really real to um
to really draw inspiration from
so something like that would be great
but you know i'm so open um
i think saying yes a lot is really good
especially when you haven't got a lot of
experience and i trust the people that
have around me to guide me in the right
direction so i'm really very very open
when it comes to a superhero movie would
you want to be a hero or a villain
i think i would
be i think i would want to be a hero but
i think i would be a good villain
seems like the villain thing is so much
fun it seems like the costumes are much
more fun yeah i want the costume i want
to
i want to fly probably what else do i
want to do loads all the stuff all the
all the tricks on wires and stuff which
is again stuff cinematically that i
haven't done just yet so yeah do you
also see yourself wanting to do things
behind the camera get into producing or
directing yeah so i write i write music
and i um i'm writing a screenplay at the
minute as well so like i'm definitely
i'm a creative person at heart so i'm
definitely exploring all of that sort of
stuff right now like i'm focused on the
acting thing and i i
i'm gonna hopefully
go into other avenues the later i get on
in my career the more experience i have
um but i've got stories to tell and i
i'm gonna tell them so yeah
it's also the it's also the best
hands-on film school to be yeah i know
100 yeah
for sure you certainly learn a lot when
you're surrounded by it
yeah for sure well awesome thank you so
much for talking to me you're really so
terrific in this i i appreciate it
oh thank you so much thank you lovely
talking to you too